Speaker 1: All right, let's go on to the next
segment, which is going to anger many people
in my audience. I got a ton of it, so let me
back up. Last week, we looked at this interview
that Jordan Peterson did with Joe Rogan, and
the interview was just word salad after word
salad of meaningless stuff. And predictably, I
got a lot of emails from people saying, David,
you might not have understood what Jordan
Peterson was saying, but it made a lot of sense.
In particular, his rant about the Bible. And
unfortunately, you're wrong. What Jordan Peterson
said about about the Bible did not make a lot
of sense, and so we're going to go through now.
We did an overview of the interview last week.
Now we're going to focus in specifically on Jordan
Peterson's rant about the Bible, which makes no
sense. And there's a really good there's this
subreddit called Ask a Historian. Some people
would say, ask an historian that that's
a grammatical preference, and I'm going to
summarize some of the comments here. The Reddit
user who wrote this out is Kiwi Hellenistic,
who's an expert in early Greek literature.
So let's go through the video and we are now going
to really focus it on the substance. It is an
unintelligible word salad, and it's also wrong
on the substance. So let's just jump right in.
Speaker 3: So I just walked through the Museum
of the Bible in Washington. That was very cool.
It's very cool music. So that structure, that's
what the book is, what I figured out. I mean,
I just figured this out this week. So it was a
cool it was a cool thing to walk through because
it's it's chronological. They have one floor,
which is the history of the Bible. Hmm. It's
not exactly that. It's really what it is is the
history of the book right now. In many ways,
the first book was the Bible, OK?
Speaker 1: In many ways, the first book
was the Bible. Now what does he mean by that? He
says he's talking about the history of the book,
not the content. OK, so if that's what he means,
the first book was not the Bible. Books date back
to the start of the second millennium. B.C.
The Bible dates to no earlier than the seventh
century B.C. or B.C., as is now often said.
Some of it came much later than that even,
and the New Testament is even newer. So, OK, first
statement. The first book was not the Bible. It's
just it's a factually incorrect statement.
Speaker 3: I mean, literally because
at one point there was only one book. OK.
Speaker 1: I mean, literally, it was
the first book because at one point
there was only one book at one point.
I guess there was only one
book, but it wasn't the Bible.
It was the Bible was not that book.
Speaker 3: Like as far as our Western
culture is concerned, there is one book.
Speaker 1: No, that's that's not true. The
Hebrew Bible is made up of a bunch of different
texts, and they were written over a period of
time that is about 500 years. And prior to
that, there were many books that were written.
It's what he's saying is it's it's
factually untrue. There's no I mean,
I'm like over explaining, it's just not true.
Speaker 3: And for a while, literally,
there was only one book and that book was the
Bible. And then before it was the Bible, it was a,
you know, it was scrolls and it was writings
on papyrus. And but it was we were starting
to aggregate written texts together, and it went
through all sorts of technological transformations
and then it became books that everybody could
buy the book everybody could buy in. The first
one of those was the Bible, and then it became
all sorts of books that everybody could buy.
But all those books, in some sense, emerged out
of that underlying book and that book itself,
the Bible isn't a book, it's a library.
Speaker 1: Now, there's actually almost
nothing to fact check there. You know, the
writings on papyrus, those were the books
of the time. So to say that because it was on
papyrus, they're not really books, it ignores
the reality of the times. Not all future books
emerged from the Bible, either, like the Odyssey
was written in the 8th century BCE that didn't
emerge from the Bible. Most of the Iliad is
older than the Bible. That's a book, whether it
was written on papyrus or not. And then there's
this sort of last thing he says here Oh, if the
Speaker 3: Bible isn't a book, it's a library.
Speaker 1: The Bible isn't a book. It's a library.
Speaker 3: It's a collection of books.
Speaker 1: OK? It's not really clear what he
means by that. The Bible is a book made up of
different passages, written at different times and
assembled together. It's a pretty vague statement
and as the culmination of everything else that he
said, that's straight up wrong. It's not really
worth much one way or the other to say the Bible
is a library. It's not just that if it sounds like
a word salad, we're not smart enough to understand
it. To all the people emailing me, insisting
me how right he is. He is wrong. He is wrong. It
doesn't make any sense. It doesn't mean everything
he says is wrong, but he's completely wrong
about just about everything he said in that clip.
Let me know your thoughts. You can
find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We depend on you here at The David Pakman Show and
after we were brutally attacked by Alex Jones, it
is even more important that you grab those
memberships at join Pacman dot com. One of the
great member benefits is the bonus show and Alex
Jones yesterday attacking the bonus show. Now
that bonus show is award winning awards. We give
out, sure, but now it is not only award winning,
but it's also been absolutely brutalized by
Alex Jones. You can find out why he's so mad
about the bonus show by signing up
at Join Pacman Dot Com and you can
use the coupon code Wow twenty two to get a
discount from the membership of your choice